Ich, okay.
Was ist da?
Schönen guten Tag.
Mein Name ist Eileen Röfcevic.
Ich bin der Dienstabende Arzt auf der Station.
Ich werde mit Ihnen das Aufnahmengespräch führen.
Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja, natürlich.
Können Sie das irgendwie schaffen, dass Sie ein bisschen lauter sind?
Okay.
Ja, ich habe das auch.
Ich werde Ihnen jetzt ein paar Fragen zu Ihrer Person stellen
und dann direkt auch zu Ihrer Beschwerden übergeben.
Wenn Sie Fragen haben oder etwas nicht verstehen,
geben Sie mir wieder eine Zeichen und dann machen wir
eine kleine Pause, okay?
Alles klar.
Wie heißen Sie den?
Ich heiße Magdalene Schmidt.
Am Ende mit DT.
Double T.
Double T, okay.
Ja, ganz ungewöhnlich.
Okay.
Wie alt sind Sie, Frau Schmidt?
Ich bin 56 Jahre alt.
56.
Wann sind Sie genau gebaut, Frau Schmidt?
Am 11.
16.
Okay.
Wie viel wiegen Sie zurzeit?
Hmm, ich wiege 79 kg.
97.
Okay.
Wie groß sind Sie?
1,68 m.
8,6 m.
Okay.
Wo wohnen Sie?
Oh, ich wohne in Reine.
Wer ist Ihre Hausart oder Herr Hausarzt?
Dr.
Eisek.
Mit Eisek.
E-I.
Okay.
Wann, was sind Sie vom Beruf?
Ich bin Reiseverkehrskaufraub.
Reiseverkehr.
Also ich arbeite im Reisebüro.
Okay.
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Ich bin verheiratet, ja.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, ich habe einen Sohn und zwei Töchter und schon drei Enkel gehen nach.
Oh, super.
Und sind Sie gesund?
Alle sind gesund, ja, zum Glück.
Okay.
Welche Beschwärmungen haben Sie?
Ja, also Herr Doktor,
mein rechter Arm macht mir so Sorgen.
Der ist mit einmal geschwollen.
Ja, er tut mir auch weh.
Ich habe das Gefühl, dass es spannend in dem Arm.
Und der fühlt sich auch ein bisschen warm an
und sieht auch rot aus.
Und ja, das ist ein ganz unangenehmes Gefühl.
Und das schmerzt auch wichtig.
Okay.
Könnten Sie bitte die Schmerzen ein bisschen beschreiben?
Zum Beispiel Stechen oder...
Vielleicht am Ehepaar?
Spannung und Druck, würde ich sagen.
Spannung und Druck.
Okay.
Und strahlen die Schmerzen in eine andere Körperregion auf?
Nein, die sind eigentlich auf den Arm beschränkt.
Auf den Arm beschränkt die Schmerzen, ja.
Ja, so in die Hand, das geht bis in die Hand rein, ja.
Also das ist alles geschwollen.
Okay, zum Beispiel in den Wurst oder in der Rückmütung.
Okay, super.
In den Rückmütung strahlt es nicht aus.
Okay.
Wann haben die Schmerzen genau begonnen?
Oh ja, aber merkt man, dass es weh tut.
Ich habe es vor zwei, drei Tagen.
Vor zwei, okay.
Wie haben die Schmerzen begonnen, plötzlich oder langsam auftreten?
Ja, ich glaube, dass es eher so langsam war.
Erst mal nimmt man das ja nicht wahr, dass da irgendwas ist,
dann denkt man, ja gut, was weiß ich, falsch bewegt.
Und dann merkt man, dass die Schmerzen nicht besser werden
und dass sie eher schlechter werden.
Ja, irgendwann ist dann so ein Punkt erreicht, wo man sagt,
oh, das ist aber jetzt doof.
Und dann guckt man auch genauer hin und sieht,
dass da was anders aussieht als sonst.
Und so war das jetzt.
Okay.
Und ich merke das auch, ich kann den Arm nicht so gut bewegen.
Also der sperrt so ein bisschen beim Knicken.
Und ja, das tut mir weh beim Bewegen.
Okay, bei Bewegung.
Okay.
Und wenn wir eine Schmerzskalle haben, von 1 bis 10,
1 sehr leichte Schmerzen, 10 unerträglichen Schmerzen.
Wie schätzen die Schmerzen ein?
Ja, so unerträglich sind die natürlich nicht.
Aber das sind schon ordentliche Schmerzen.
Ich sage mal so bei 6 vielleicht.
6, okay.
Und Sie haben rechte Arm.
Könnten Sie mir bitte zeigen, zum Beispiel
in der Ellenboden oder unter Arm?
Also eigentlich ist der ganze Arm geschwollen.
Der ganze Arm ist geschwollen und tut weh.
Und das geht so bis in die Hand rein.
Okay.
Und gibt es auslösende Faktoren,
die für die Schmerzen verantwortlich sind?
Zum Beispiel nach der,
eigentlich Sie haben schon gesagt, bei Bewegung.
Und tut es mehr weh, ja.
Genau.
Okay.
Und ich denke, es ist ein bisschen besser,
wenn ich den so ein bisschen hoch halte.
Oder wenn ich im Bett liege und den so auf den Kisten lege,
dann ist es ein bisschen besser mit den Schmerzen.
Aber das ist ja kein Zustand.
Ich muss ja mit meinem Arm umlaufen können.
Okay.
Und haben Sie noch andere Beschwerden, zum Beispiel Fieber
oder, ähm,
Fieber habe ich nicht.
Okay.
Übelkeit oder Abregion oder.
Nein, nein, sonst habe ich eigentlich nichts.
Okay.
Und sind bei Ihnen,
ihr gibt welche Vorerkrankungen?
Ja, ähm, klar.
Ich habe schon einiges, was ich so an Belastung mitbringe.
Vor 14 Jahren hatte ich eine Brustoperation auf der rechten Seite.
Okay.
Wurzeln.
Bitte.
Warum würden Sie wegen wegen Brustkrebs?
Brustkrebs.
Okay.
Vor 14 Jahren, oder?
Vor 14 Jahren.
Okay.
Und.
Wurden die ganze Brust untergezogen?
Oder enttäuscht?
Ja, es wurde Brust erhalten, operiert.
Okay.
Rechter Brust, rechter Brust.
Und noch andere Vorerkrankungen.
Ja, ich habe ein bisschen hohen Blutdruck, wie das so ist,
und ein bisschen erhöhte Blutfettwerte.
Und vor einem Jahr habe ich eine neue Hüfte bekommen.
Welche Seite?
Recht.
Recht scheint meine schlechte Seite zu sein.
Okay.
Nehmen Sie dagegen, zum Beispiel gegen Blutdruck oder Blut,
erhöhte Blutfettwerte, etwas ein.
Ja, ich nehme Konko auf 5.
Einmal täglich.
Und die Hauan 160 ein.
160.
Einmal täglich.
Nach der Operation haben Sie gegen Brustkrebs,
einige Medikamente oder Chemotherapie.
Ja, aber das ist alles abgeschlossen.
Das ist ja schon lange her.
Okay.
Gibt es besondere Krankheiten in Ihrer Familie?
Da muss ich richtig überlegen.
Also meine Mutter hatte auch Hüftprobleme.
Und die hat auch ein bisschen hohen Blutdruck.
Mein Vater ist schon früh gestorben.
Der hat den Herz entfragt.
Da war er noch keine 60.
Und meine Schwester hatte jetzt auch vor einem Jahr
eine Brustoperation.
Die ist ein bisschen jünger als ich.
Vor einem Jahr.
Ja, vor einem Jahr war das.
Okay.
Und mein Bruder, der hatte auch vor vier Jahren ein Herz entfragt.
Der hat den aber ganz gut überstanden.
Ja, ist gut.
Aber, ja, okay.
Ihre Schwester vor einem Jahr Brust-Obey auch wegen Brustkrebs,
oder?
Ja, ja.
Okay.
Und sind Sie schon in der Menepode?
Ja.
Okay.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Stuhlgang oder was alles?
Normalerweise eigentlich nicht.
Okay.
Und Sie haben sich in der letzten Zeit verändert?
Ja, tatsächlich habe ich gemerkt,
dass ich ein bisschen Gewicht zugenommen habe,
obwohl ich eigentlich nicht mehr esse.
Das ist nur zwei Kilo,
habe ich in den letzten Wochen zugenommen.
Okay.
Und haben Sie Probleme beim Einschlafen oder durchschlafen?
Normalerweise nicht.
Ich habe nicht mehr.
Normalerweise nicht jetzt mit dem Arm.
Das macht mir so ein bisschen Sorgen.
Deswegen habe ich jetzt die letzten Nächte nicht so gut geschlafen.
Okay.
Und haben Sie Stress,
weil ich jetzt zu Hause oder zum Beispiel in der Familie?
Nein, eigentlich, da läuft alles ganz gut.
Und bei der Arbeit,
das ist eigentlich auch sehr entspannt.
Da geht es ja endlich nach Corona wieder los.
Und da sind alle froh drüber.
Okay.
Und brauchen Sie Frau Schling?
Ob ich rauche?
Nein, das habe ich nie gemacht.
Super.
Das ist sehr gut für Sie.
Und trinke Sie Alkohol?
Dahin und wieder mal ein Gläschen Sekt oder mal ein Glas Wein.
Oder im Sommer auch,
wenn es schön warm ist, mal ein Glas Bier.
Oder manchmal so,
so ein leckerer Likör oder so.
Das mag ich schon.
Aber ja, ich trinke jetzt nicht viel.
Und sind bei Ihnen Allergien oder Unverträglichkeiten bekannt?
Nicht, dass ich wüsste,
nein, da ist eigentlich nichts bekannt.
Okay.
Und eigentlich, ich möchte nur eine Frage stellen
über Ihre Schwellung.
Haben Sie bemerkt,
dass zum Beispiel in der Achselhölle einige Knötchen oder Knöten,
zum Beispiel, oder Schwellung?
Das habe ich nicht bemerkt,
habe ich aber auch nicht nachgeguckt.
Wenn ich so fühle,
ja, können Sie das sein, dass da was ist?
Ja, das fühlt sich ein bisschen geschwollen an.
Okay.
Ich habe meine alle richtiger Frage bestellt.
Und wenn Sie Fragen haben,
würde ich gerne beantworten.
Ja, also, was ist denn jetzt mit dem Arm?
Was kann man denn dagegen tun?
Ja, eigentlich, bevor ich etwas Falsches sage,
eigentlich würde ich abwarten,
bis wir alle Untersuchungen durchgeführt haben.
Was für Untersuchungen machen Sie denn?
Ja, eigentlich zuerst würde ich
Blut abnehmen und natürlich zuerst
würde ich körperliche Untersuchungen
und Blutabnehmen und dann, ja,
möchte ich auch
eine Ultraschall-Untersuchung
anfordern und, ja, danach...
Ein Ultraschall wovon?
Was wird beim Ultraschall, was wird da untersucht?
Ultraschall ist eine Untersuchung,
die schmerzfrei und strahlenfrei ist.
Das ist gut, ja?
Und natürlich...
Was fasst ihr denn da untersucht?
Kann man den Arm mit Ultraschall untersuchen?
Ja, damit mit Schallbählen
die Organe teilen können.
Zuerst einen schönen...
Wie kann man sagen?
Schallkopf, es gibt eine Schallkopf.
Wir drücken Ihre Organe zum Beispiel.
Ja, ich wollte nur wissen, welches Organ,
ob Sie den Arm untersuchen.
Ja, natürlich, rechte Arm.
Den rechten Arm würden Sie untersuchen.
Okay, alles klar.
Gut.
Sonst habe ich eigentlich weiter keine Fragen.
Eigentlich, ja, ich habe meine alle Frage gestattet.
Und wenn Sie keine Frage haben,
können wir körperlich uns übergeben.
Alles klar.
Haben unsere Kolleginnen Fragen?
Meine Frage nicht, aber...
Ich habe ein paar Fragen, ja?
Ein paar gleich, oh je, oh je.
Also ich würde gerne wissen,
haben Sie schon mal so eine ähnliche Situation?
Sie haben vor 14 Jahren, okay, ne?
Vielleicht haben Sie so eine ähnliche Situation.
Das ist die erste Frage.
Also zweites, haben Sie im letzter Zeit
Ihrem rechten Arm eine Wunder gesehen
oder eine kleine Frage passiert, so was?
Ich möchte das auch wissen.
Das sind zwei sehr gute Fragen, ja, okay.
Also zuerst nein, die Patientin hat so eine Arm-Spellung
noch nicht vorher erlebt.
Und ihr ist tatsächlich auch keine Wunde aufgefallen am Abend.
Danke schön.
Ja, gerne.
Entschuldigung.
Das macht unerwürft.
Halli, kannst du voll bereit?
Ja, ich brauche ein bisschen Zeit.
Ja, okay.
Wie wollen wir ihm gönnen, ne?
Ja, genau.
Sie hat selber gesagt,
dass der Arm dick und rot ist.
Also gerötet ist.
Und dann fragen kann man natürlich,
ist Ihnen aufgefallen, dass der Arm geschwollen ist?
Ist Ihnen aufgefallen, dass der Arm
gerötet ist oder eine andere Farbe hat?
Ist die Frage beantwortet damit?
Eigentlich, ich habe nicht schrieben.
Ich habe jemanden, der hier schriftlich eingegeben hat.
Entschuldigung, ich habe jetzt...
Okay, ja.
Alles klar, gerne.
Ja, Sie waren da beschäftigt.
Wobei nach Schmerzen hatte er ja auch gefragt
und auch sehr ausführlich.
Wobei das für mich tatsächlich immer schwierig ist,
in der Simulation Schmerzen zu beschreiben,
die ich tatsächlich nicht habe.
Das ist immer eine Herausforderung.
Da muss man sich immer sehr überlegen,
wie wir sein könnten.
Ja, wir können...
Guten Tag Frau Oberärztin.
Heute haben wir eine Patientin,
ich will gerne mit Ihnen mitteilen.
Haben Sie Zeit?
Ja, natürlich.
Okay, der Patient...
Entschuldigung, die Patientin, die 56-Jährige,
die 56 Jahre alt ist,
hat sich wegen seit zwei oder drei bestehenden,
langsam aufgetretenen,
prägriente, spannende, drückende, dumpfende
ganzen Rechten ein Schmerzen ohne Strahlung vorgestellt.
Und die Patientin gab an,
dass ihre Rechten ein Rot- und Überwarmung habe.
Und außerdem, die sagte,
die sagte ihre Rechten ein,
sei geschwollen,
an Vorerkrankungen,
sei Blut und Atelierlihypertoni,
und Hyperlyptomy.
Vor 14 Jahren wurde Brustkrebs bestehend
und auch Hüftenschuldigung,
an Vorerkrankungen,
sei Atelierlihypertoni und Hyperlyptomy bekannt.
Und auch sie wurde in ihrer rechten Hüfte
rechte Kokzer kooperiert.
Und vor 14 Jahren wurde sie,
wurde bei ihr Brust,
ja, Mama Karstin, festgestattet.
Und in ihrer Familie,
in einer Miese, zeigte sich,
dass die Mutter,
die Mutter,
habe Hüfte Probleme gehabt.
Und der Vater,
habe,
haben Joghurt im Park bis gelitten.
Ihre Schwester,
und Bruder,
ihre Bruder,
aber auch Joghurt im Park bis gelitten.
Und sie ist schon meine Pose.
Und ja, Vegetativ in einer Mese
sind unauffällig bis auf
Gewichtverlust
in einer Woche.
Sie nehme
Gewichtverlust.
Ja, sorry, Gewichtszunahme.
Gewichtszunahme.
Sie nehmen 5 Milligramm einmal täglich
und Diaban 160 Milligramm einmal täglich.
Sie ist nicht traurig.
Sie trinkt
gelegentlich ein Glas Wein
oder ein Glas Bier oder ein Glas,
ein kleiner Likon.
Und sie
ist, ja,
Entschuldigung,
weil Allergien und Unfälle
bei Trägigkeiten sein,
keine bekannt.
Ja, das war es.
Was ist denn jetzt Ihre Verdachtsiagnose?
Eigentlich
auf Brut der erwähnten Angaben
gehe ich von Verdacht auf
vielleicht
wieder Brustplats
auf Trät oder Brustplats
Mama Karlsynom.
Also ein Rezidiv.
Ein Rezidiv, das mag ich.
Rezidiv, Mama Karlsynom auf.
Was wäre Alternativen?
Differentialdiagnose?
Differentialdiagnostisch kommen.
Erdipel zum Beispiel.
Lymphoderm zum Beispiel.
So wie
Was ist denn das eigentlich das naheliegendste,
wenn der Arm
geschwollen ist
und schmerzhaft
beim Bein wäre das eindeutig, da würde man da sofort
drauf kommen.
Eigentlich habe ich nicht ganz verstanden.
Was liegt denn noch ein bisschen näher
als das Eresipel vielleicht?
Was vermutet man denn als erstes
bei einer Schwellung der Extremität?
Infektion, oder zum Beispiel
vielleicht
Romatismal Probleme,
Arteritis.
Es könnte sein, genau.
Also, dass da vielleicht eine Trombose
oder eine Trombophygiene ist, wenn es in dem Arm ist.
Das würde man vermuten.
Was machen Sie denn diagnostisch mit der Patientin?
Ja, zur Abklärung empfehle ich
folgende Untersuchungen zum Beispiel.
Zuerst körperliche Untersuchungen.
Worauf achten Sie bei der körperlichen Untersuchung?
Ja, grob.
Die Große von rechtem Arm
oder Vergleichung der andere Seite.
Wie vergleichen Sie das denn?
Der andere Arm.
Wie vergleichen Sie die Bar?
Wie machen Sie das?
Ein banales Hilfsmittel,
das man dazu nimmt.
Wie können eigentlich messen?
Ja, die Umfangmessung.
Und, was machen Sie noch?
Und auch, wir können abtasten
die Arterien oder Pulse.
Und auch, wir können überprüfen,
ob es über Warmung
oder
drückende Ödem.
Ja, genau.
Und, wie kann man das?
Ja, und Sie haben die Patientin ja selber gefragt,
ob sie
in der Achselhölle was getastet hat.
Also, was machen Sie auch?
Wir können natürlich
in ihrer Achselhölle kontrollieren.
Die Luftknoten, das nicht?
Ja, und
die Arterien, die wir haben,
die Arterien, die wir haben.
Ja, und Sie haben,
was machen Sie noch, nach der körperlichen Untersuppung?
Und, wir können
Entzündungsparameter
anfordern.
Ja, okay. Auf welchem Arm nehmen Sie den Blut ab?
Natürlich, in der linken Seite.
Ja, sehr schön.
Was machen Sie noch?
Auf alle Fälle.
Was ist die Nutzwerte,
Sie haben getragt, oder nicht?
Ja, die auch, aber was machen Sie noch auf alle Fälle?
Wenn Sie das Blut ins Labor geben,
was kreuzt Sie Sie noch an? Auf alle Fälle.
Kleines Öl, CRP, BST,
oder?
Ja, das ist ein anderes.
Denken Sie mal an den Trombosevorder.
Trombosevorder, BEDEMARE, zum Beispiel.
Ja, okay, alles klar.
Gut, und was kommt dann als operative Untersuchung?
Ja, wir könnten
Udreschale anfordern.
Ja.
Oder Luplexsonografie, oder?
Wir können
Trombose
feststellen.
Genau.
Oder mit Ultraschale können wir
unter der Haufe, Ödemähe,
oder der andere, zum Beispiel,
einsymhy, oder der andere,
eitrige Flüssigensammlung
können wir feststellen.
Gut, ja.
Für den Fall,
dass sich bestätigt Ihre Diagnose,
dass die eine
Wenenentzündung hat in dem Arzt, oder eine Trombose.
Was machen Sie dann mit der Patientin?
Ja, eigentlich
sollte man
mit Antibiosen
behandeln.
Warum Antibiosen?
Eigentlich, ich habe gehört Tromboclebitis.
Ach so, ja, genau.
Ja, stimmt, ja, das richtig.
Ja, wegen Entzündung muss man Antibiosen behandeln.
Aber was noch auf alle Fälle?
Flexan, oder?
Ja, genau. Also, Heparin bzw.
Blutverdünnungspel.
Gut, was machen Sie noch?
Was braucht die noch um den Arm rum?
Vielleicht, wie können Kalt
kühlen?
Kühlen ist gut, ja.
Was bietet sich da an?
Ein bisschen wie können
aufheben?
Hochlagern, meinst du.
Hochlagern kühlen, genau.
Und, was machen wir noch?
Vielleicht können wir ein bisschen streichern, aber
bandageieren.
Genau genommen braucht die
tatsächlich einen richtigen Kompressionsverband.
Und eigentlich
auch für eine Weile
eine Kompression.
Also, jetzt bandagiert man erst mal und
dann, wenn die das länger braucht,
die muss es ja sicherlich mehrere Wochen tragen.
Dann muss sie einen Kompression,
einen Arm Kompression tragen.
Wenn sich das zeigt,
dass es ein Lümpferdem ist,
was machen wir dann?
Das ist eine besondere Massage.
Das hilft diese Lymphen.
Ja, und natürlich
muss man, das haben Sie ja eigentlich als allererstes gesagt,
Ihr Verdacht war ja ein Rezidiv
vom Mamakatzinom.
Das heißt, das müsste man,
tatsächlich, wenn wir es als Lymphen dem diagnostizieren,
müsste man das Rezidiv des Mamakatzinomes auf alle Fälle ausschließen.
Ja, natürlich.
Oder nach der Operation kann man auch
Komplikation bekommen.
Ja, es gibt tatsächlich so eine Geschichte,
dass Leute, also auch viele,
viele Jahre nach der eigentlichen Brust-OP,
wenn die überhaupt nicht mehr daran denken,
dass sie diesen Arm schonen sollen,
dass die tatsächlich einmal irgendwie
wie Gartenarbeit machen oder eine schwere Tasche tragen
oder sich irgendwie ungewöhnlich belasten
und dass das Auslöser ist
für ein Lymphedem, was vorher nicht da war.
Ja, ganz gemacht.
Ich bin sehr begeistert, dass sie überhaupt auf die Idee gekommen sind
mit dem Lymphedem,
weil das tatsächlich viele so gar nicht auf dem Schirm haben.
Ja, gut, dann bin ich gespannt,
untersuchen Sie Ihre Patientin
und erzählen Sie mir bitte, was rausgekommen ist.
Und ich bin sehr gespannt auf die weitere Entwicklung.
Ja?
Danke, ich mache hervor.
Alles klar.
Gut. Ja, hat noch jemand Fragen dazu
oder Anmerkungen, Kommentare?